here I'd like to go over a list of areas
that require attention some of this will
be no news to you some of it perhaps
toxic disposal we don't have a theory of
toxic disposal what we have is a theory
of toxic hiding shell games postponement
tabeling we need a real method of toxic
disposal until it comes we continue to
sequester radioactive and toxic
materials throughout the world in the
body of the earth many of these toxic
materials have half-lives of hundreds of
thousands of years again yesterday's
newspaper greenpeace reported
encountering a soviet frigate in the sea
of japan dumping nuclear cores and
nuclear coolant into the Sea of Japan
where the Japanese population draws 30%
of its sea cash we need toxic disposal
plants have a role to play here many of
you know that the solanaceous plants
like the jimsonweed and the datura
sequester heavy metals but these this
information has not been made the
centerpiece of a crash program to clean
up the land simply because people do not
care enough or rather human institutions
read corporations do not care enough
environmental restoration another area
where tiny pilot projects are held up in
such a fashion to give people permission
to think well that's under control at
least we don't have to worry about that
most of the restoration programs that
you hear about are in fact cosmetic
efforts designed to divert your
attention from some greater horror being
perpetuated somewhere else you have to
be
very sophisticated because the enemy
you're playing with is incredibly
sophisticated
we need planet friendly technologies an
obvious one is hydrogen hydrogen when
burned in an automobile or a boiler
combines with oxygen to produce water it
is a technology that is non polluting
and by developing liquid natural gas
storage and transportation technologies
we have proven that we can handle
hydrogen hydrogen is highly explosive
but if you blow up a hydrogen loading or
unloading depot all you have is a very
violent localized explosion you don't
have planetary contamination of the
water and the air hydrogen is the
direction in which we should be moving
and the people who have studied it have
put in place all kinds of technological
schemes for bringing it to us but the
problem is that those who are already
peddling natural gas and petroleum
byproducts are not interested in this
scheme their loyalty then is not to the
species or to the planet but the bottom
line in any civilized society putting
the bottom line ahead of civilization
and planet would be a hanging offense
but not here
another area population control this is
one that everyone agrees with but the
facts of the matter have not I think
been fully explored a child born to a
woman in San Francisco or Malibu will
consume between eight hundred and a
thousand times the natural resources of
a child born to a woman in Bangladesh
where do we preach birth control that's
right Bangladesh
the women who could make the didn't
notice that if every woman had one child
the population of this planet would fall
by 50% in one generation now without war
without famine without displacement of
populations the population of the planet
would fall by half in the lifetime of
most people sitting here I don't think
people realize this we tend to assume
the population problem is unstoppable
the women most likely to hear the
message that one woman one child leads
to a saner world are the highly educated
women of the high-tech industrial
democracies the kind of women sitting in
this room since their children are using
800 to a thousand times more resources
than the children of the third world if
10 to 15 percent of the women in the
high-tech industrial democracies were to
follow this policy the release of
pressure on world resources would be
visible within 10 to 15 years now I
realize these suggestions are highly
controversial and I have a number of
them so I don't want to we could hold a
whole conference on that concept mmm the
other thing another item we need to
deconstruct product fetishism we need to
through the media establish the idea
that a zen-like spareness
is the highest expression of social
consciousness when it comes to interior
decorating the building of country
houses and so forth and so on
deconstruct product fetishism so that
the the Kikuyu or the yanomamö become
the Paragons
of behavior in terms of relating to
material existence we do not need to
sell our souls to junk and then inherit
a ruined planet it makes no sense at all
this is a problem because the techniques
of capitalism are to use advertising to
spread discontent they are selling you
something you don't already have
discontent is the obvious way to move
you to make that purchase so you're
constantly being bombarded with images
of your own inadequacy unless you have
the correct running shoes German
automobile or a house in the country
next item demilitarization there there
is much talk about getting rid of
nuclear weapons because the leadership
of these bankrupt fascist oligarchies
could themselves be incinerated by
nuclear weapons but where is the
lantern-jawed lab from alabama on the
subject of getting rid of all armies on
this planet now is the moment because
there are not large crystallized power
blocks set against each other how about
a 15 percent reduction in all military
budgets across the board no one can
claim that their security is lessened
because their enemies too would reduce
military spending apparently there's a
big game going on dealing all this
lethal junk all over the world and
that's why there's no mention of
demilitarizing even such regimes as the
Haitian or the Somalian regime it is
apparently a natural right of Dominator
jerks to have as much weaponry as they
can buy with the money they steal and
squeezed out of their captive
populations another area
democratic values and human rights
democratic values and human rights you
cannot build an
consciousness out of a population of
slaves ruled by oligarchs and that is
the situation for one third of the human
species so long as the octogenarian
trash that rules China is in place where
is our government on that issue and that
leads me to government accountability
are we making our governments
accountable in the matter of preserving
the environment cleaning up toxic waste
disposing of the manufacturing processes
of these oh so necessary weapons
stockpiles that these characters feel
they have have to have well that's a
pretty nuts and bolts laundry list not
the sort of thing you're used to hearing
from me I think hearing a list like that
the census may be great list but it's a
little overwhelming in the demands that
it makes how are we to fulfill these
many agendas at once and this is where
we come to my bailiwick it is less than
a hundred years since the great
stabilizing and illuminating force in
the lives of archaic people has come to
the attention of Western civilization
the great stabilizing and illuminating
force in the lives of archaic people is
there a vegetable connection to the
Gaian mind their ability to
experientially not abstract reasoning
like I've been doing here to
experientially feel the planet our
mother it's needs its tensions where it
is in pain
they do this through the ingestion of
psychoactive plants they did this
through the ingestion of psychoactive
plants for fifty to a hundred thousand
years before the extra mentally brained
monotheists degree culturalist faction
arose the greatest gift of the vegetable
mind to the human order is the
psychedelic experience because it allows
the dissolution of boundaries and it is
going to be necessary to dissolve those
boundaries in order to coordinate the
metamorphosis of the human world we have
to have a vision I don't mean a plan I
don't mean an agenda I mean a vision and
you don't the vision comes from above it
comes from call it the unconscious call
it the Gaian mind call it the Great
Spirit it doesn't come out of committee
meetings and the data gathered by
statistical analysis we lack at the
highest level not you and not me but at
the controlling level we lack a vision
the best leaders among us are no more
than crisis managers attempting to
manage us past and apocalypse that they
are coming to believe is inevitable that
isn't good enough that's not what my
daddy raised me for and it's not what
your daddy raised you for we represent
the cutting edge of novelty in the
biological world our self-reflective
consciousness is our great glory it also
opens for us a dimension of moral
responsibility unknown to the rest of
the denizens of nature part of our
Promethean and godlike aspiration to the
control of nature
is the concomitant obligation to care
for nature and to feel nature so really
my my message here is a message of
psychedelic empowerment of feeling the
ideas will come the ratiocination will
come but what we have to do is feel our
dilemma if we could feel our dilemma and
make other people feel our dilemma we
would move rapidly toward real solutions
we are anesthetized we are a world dying
under anesthesia for lack of authentic
experience authentic connection with the
living world out of which we came
recently just this past week I read a
wonderful book which I recommend called
going to the heart by Kenny Greene or
good I think an anthropologist who lived
with the Yanomami the important thing
about this book is he lived with him for
12 years but he married a young girl of
the tribe and it tells the story of
their life in the Amazon and their life
in Rutherford New Jersey I mean this
this woman had never seen an outboard
motor the it was a wonderful book I was
skeptical when I began reading it I just
thought you know why do I have to read
about some guy who trophies a woman in
the Amazon I feel very badly for my
judgement on it because the message of
that book is ultimately a message of
love a message of reaching across
incredible barriers of culture and time
and space to the essential humaneness
that unites all of us and if we can do
this by whatever techniques are
available if we can create a sense of
community
globally then attending that sense of
community will be a sense of caring and
responsibility it cannot happen unless
we change our minds we have the
technologies the money the logistical
ability to do almost anything in the
human world but we don't know how to
change our minds we are angels with a
Siamese twin who is a monkey growing out
of our chests and this was all very fine
when there were endless environments to
despoil and vast herds of game that
curious amalgam of the animal and the
angelic that is our humaneness could
exist in that kind of an environment but
no more and for the past thousand years
the moral bankruptcy of Western
civilization has become more and more
apparent the chickens are coming home to
roost we must build community and we
must do it in a short time if we had 500
years to debate this and make our case I
don't think I would be advocating
psychedelic intervention but we're sick
we're terminal we've lost our compass we
don't know who we are we don't know
where we want to go we our own lives are
an experience of inadequacy and tension
we have lost our compass but it's there
and not because the psychedelics are a
magical panacea the psychedelics lift
the veil on the intention of the Gaian
mind
and we are but atoms in that guy in mind
if we do not follow its purpose
we have no purpose who do we think we
are Western science is 600 years old
human beings have been on this planet 2
million years life one point four
billion years there is an enormous
wisdom in biology and we must become
able to tap into that articulate it and
then activate it
we are the crowning achievement of the
evolutionary process
let's not betray it let's make it be
ascent to angelic being that is I am
sure the intention of the guy in mind
and all the rest of the life with which
we share this planet thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]